As strange as the
creatures of the microcosmos are,
their lives still revolve around the
same fundamentals that ours do.
There’s food, there's reproduction,
and there's death.
Yes, even microbes, hardy as they can be,
experience death.
In some ways, you could say they invented it.
And on our journey through the microcosmos,
we’ve watched those deaths through many lenses.
Some are slow, calm affairs, while others
are explosive or creepy.
And today, we’re going to try
something new for our channel.
We have gathered a few of our favorite episodes
about death in the microcosmos so that we
can see where our journey has taken us.
So yeah, this is the kind of video you can
turn on, and leave on for awhile.
This first video is also one of our oldest,
so you’ll notice that a lot of
footage in it looks very different from what
we show these days because thanks to the support
of our viewers, we’ve been
able to upgrade our microscope
multiple times over the
course of this show.
So the microscope may be different.
But the death, well, the death remains the
same.
This round little unicellular creature came
to us via a plankton net, a mesh with tiny,
microscopic holes through which we ran hundreds
and hundreds of liters of water, letting us
collect anything too large to pass through.
We haven’t been able to identify this species
yet, making it a bit of a mystery.
But the bigger mystery is still to come because
this little creature is about to undergo that
most universal and unknowable
experience of all, death.
Death comes to the microcosmos in many forms.
Like this Stentor Polymorphous, slowly expelling
the contents of its once trumpet-like body
into the surrounding environment.
Or this dead larva, whose exoskeleton is now
an inanimate host to two unicellular organisms.
Even the mighty tardigrade, which has survived
as a species through multiple mass extinctions,
is not immune to death.
This is, of course, the natural order of things.
Predators hunt, and their prey attempts to
survive, with varying levels of success.
This is Loxophyllum meleagris, a large unicellular
organism that we’ve shown before eating a rotifer.
This one is practically stuffed with those multicellular
creatures, we counted five rotifers inside of it.
But sometimes the predator becomes the prey,
and even the Loxophyllum meleagris has to
find ways to ensure its survival when other
species come after it.
This seemingly unlikely threat is the Lacrymaria
olor.
Its name in Latin means “tears of a swan”,
a name that suits both its teardrop shape
and its neck-like extension, which gets up to
eight times longer than its body in search of prey.
Sometimes, we can see its neck poking out
of the dirt on our microscope slide.
But even knowing that, you’d be forgiven
for thinking it unlikely that something so
small could pose a problem for those larger
Loxophyllum.
And yet, the Lacrymaria manages to take quite
a chunk out of the Loxophyllum.
The Loxophyllum though, survives thanks to its
ability to regenerate the piece that was taken,
but not all prey gets so lucky.
Here, this rotifer has been killed by a heliozoan,
destined to become food, a fate that this
flagellate is about to share as it becomes
captured by a heliozoan that is in the middle
of cell division.
The flagellate has been trapped by those long
extensions, called axopods, that radiate out
from the heliozoan’s body.
As the flagellate comes further in, it will
be engulfed by the cells into its own food
compartment called a vacuole.
There, it will be lysed open and its contents
digested by the heliozoa.
In the end though, the natural order comes
for predators too.
Here, another heliozoan’s dying cellular
body attracts the various
decomposers of the microbial world.
Aside from predators, there are many other
factors that lead a single-celled organism
to die, changes in temperature, oxygen
concentration, pH, water quality, so much more.
This single-celled organism is swollen because
the water surrounding it is entering the cell
via osmosis.
Many organisms have water pumps called contractile
vacuoles that they use to push water back
out and prevent that swelling.
But as in the case of this organism, sometimes
those contractile vacuoles stop working,
and when that happens,
the cell swells and explodes.
Other times, the cause of death is harder
to determine, like this Paradileptus that
spent several hours swimming before going
still, its shape beginning to change until
it melts away, seeming to kill not only the
Paradileptus but this small green cell swimming
nearby, but leaving other smaller flagellates
seemingly unaffected.
And this brings us back to the beginning,
with our mystery organism that is about to
undergo a death laden with more mysteries.
At first, the cell looks like it’s just
melting away, dissolving into something that
resembles a microbial Milky Way, except that
for a few seconds, it almost looks like the
cell membrane is able to close itself back up.
We think, though we can’t know for sure,
that some of the mechanisms inside the cell
are still working, and that the organism is
trying to recover.
But alas, survival is not in the cards.
Its membrane goes through lysis, releasing
its insides into the surrounding environment.
This death is unlike any other kind of death
we’ve observed under our microscope, and
we’re still not sure what caused it.
Perhaps there were so many organisms in the
sample that they depleted the oxygen, and
this organism could not continue cellular respiration.
But perhaps it was something else.
Death at every size holds its own mysteries,
but it also reveals.
The observations we make, even the guesses
we come up with, tell us about the way these
microbes interact with their environment,
the way their own bodies work, and the connections
that exist between them.
It is only ever in the mysteries that knowledge
is waiting to be found.
So we just saw a small fraction of how many
ways there are for microbes to die.
But maybe now you’re asking yourself a more
fundamental question: what even is death?
Well, weirdly, none of us will ever
fully know the answer.
But that doesn’t mean we can’t try to
use what we know of chemistry and life to
begin to describe it, as we’ll see in our
next video.
This is a ciliate, Loxodes magnus.
It is about to die.
Of course, depending on your time scale,
we’re all about to die.
To the grand canyon, or the sun, things that
have existed for millions or billions of years,
we are each weird little bubbles of peculiar
chemistry that form and then pop,
form, and then pop.
But this ciliate, and with our new microscope
you can really see those cilia beating, is
about to pop right before your eyes.
It looks fine right now.
You can even see, inside it, it’s last meal,
a Trachelomonas.
So we don’t think it’s starving to death.
It seems to be trucking along just fine.
Loxodes Magnus are microaerophilic organisms,
preferring a low concentration of dissolved
oxygen in their environment, but not too low.
So maybe the concentration on the slide was
too high, though we’ve witnessed many others
who have been just fine in our preparations.
So no, we can’t tell you why this ciliate
is about to die, but we can tell you that
right here, that’s where James, our master
of microscopes, first saw something strange.
The moment the ciliate shifted direction,
a little trail of cell membrane and cytoplasm.
No reason.
Nothing grabbed it, it didn’t snag on anything.
But a little bit of what was once a part of the
organism was suddenly, no longer a part of it.
That cytoplasm is full of complicated molecules
that are what chemists would call, far from equilibrium.
Equilibrium is the situation in which chemicals
no longer have a tendency to react over time.
In general, a thing that you can say for sure
is that all the stuff outside of living cells
is either at chemical equilibrium, or it is
headed there.
Whereas stuff inside cells is not at equilibrium,
and it’s not headed there either.
How are all of these chemicals that, if left
alone, would rapidly reach equilibrium managing
to not do that?
Life.
That is what life is.
A bunch of chemicals that take in energy in
order to keep each other from reaching equilibrium.
Quick break from our friend, the way we define
life in biology classes is, wrong.
It’s not even really a definition, it’s
a set of qualifying factors.
Life has to take in energy.
Life has to reproduce, it must respond to
its environment, it must consist of cells.
This is not a definition, it’s an attempt
to draw a line, to create a boundary.
And that makes sense for things that are actually
amorphous and complicated, like social constructs.
But life is not a construct of our opinions,
but of reality.
Life is a chemical system that uses energy
to keep itself from reaching chemical equilibrium.
Why do they do it?
Oh, well maybe let’s not go that deep,
at least not today.
Suffice it to say, a system that did this
developed on this planet and now, billions
of years later, it is still doing it.
We have many things in common with this ciliate,
and not to belabor the point, but one of those
things is that we will die.
You’ve may have noticed by now that this
video isn’t about what life is, it’s about
what death is.
It’s just that, first, we had to define life.
Life is chemicals working together to take
in energy to keep themselves far from equilibrium.
Death is not the return to chemical equilibrium.
The process of decay can last decades.
Likewise, many parts of my body will return
to equilibrium over the course of my life,
I’m shedding skin cells right now and so are you.
The atoms and molecules of my body are replaced
with new ones over and over and over again.
But I will only die once.
Likewise, our ciliate has been shedding cytoplasm
and cell membrane for minutes now, and that
shed cytoplasm is dead, no doubt.
But the organism lives.
Its chemistry continues.
For now.
Death is the moment when the system that maintains
the far from equilibrium state ceases existence.
And we can imagine that at many scales.
That can happen to individual bits of an organism,
as it is happening to the chemicals spilling
out of our Loxodes right now.
It can also happen to an individual cell in
an organism.
And that happens all the time.
It is happening right now inside you.
It can also happen to an organism.
That’s what we usually think of as death,
with our focus, so often, on the individual.
But we can keep moving up the scale and find
yet other kinds of death.
When a common genetic system that was useful
for keeping many similar but individual organisms
alive ceases to exist, that is an extinction.
A kind of death.
And when the system that has kept all life
on earth far from equilibrium for billions
of years, that system that we all share of
nucleic and amino acids, when that ceases
to exist, that will be something else.
A terrible kind of death that we do not even
have a name for.
But it will be a death.
The largest death, I suppose, until heat death,
when everything in the universe has found equilibrium.
Our ciliate is about out of time now.
I don’t know when we can call it, when we
can pronounce the time of death, but this
seems as good a time as any.
Here, we have death.
The system that was using energy to keep itself
from reaching equilibrium has ceased to exist.
Hey, welcome back. If you’ve come
out of that video with some
existential dread about the state of the universe,
that is very reasonable.
However, on our next stop in this journey,
we’re going to argue that sure, chemical
equilibria are scary, but if you’re a nematode,
maybe you should worry about fungi first.
There are plenty of horror stories that begin
innocuously enough.
A new home, a camping trip with friends, a
doll purchased at an estate sale….
This one starts with some ponds, the same
set of ponds that James, our master of microscopes,
has been sampling every week for the past
three years.
Which means that he’s collected so many
microbes from these waters that you might
think they’d get a bit boring or redundant.
But you should never underestimate nature’s
capacity for surprise.
Recently, James came home with some samples
from these ponds.
And as usual, he prepared some slides and
checked on the organisms within, finding some
nematodes like this one slithering about on
the slide.
And all seemed well, so he stored the slides
and his new friends in a humidity chamber
and waited to observe them after a few more
days.
But two days later, all would not be well.
This is where we build our suspense.
In a movie, this would be the moment where
we assess the unsettling basement or the dark
woods, and then consider retreating to safety.
This is the creepy doll, only there hasn’t
been any thumps in the middle of the night,
so everything seems okay, right?
We’re looking at the spores of a fungus,
one belonging to the group Arthrobotrys.
And when it’s just floating around like
this, it seems quite harmless—especially
when compared to the nematodes we showed earlier,
which are part of a whole family of worms
that are notorious for their parasitic lifestyle.
And if you were to write off Arthrobotrys
as a potential threat, you would be correct…
most of the time.
It does spend much of its life aligned with
the dead, but only to sustain itself on the
remains of decayed life and organic matter.
Arthrobotrys species are found all around
the world, occupying everything from soil
to animal feces in the many varied climates
that make up our planet.
And wherever it is, the fungus ensures that
nutrients like nitrogen from dead organisms
and other waste cycle through ecosystems.
But when nitrogen is scarce, these fungi will
resort to hunting it down from living sources.
And what better prey than the nematode, a
fellow dweller of the soil and one of the
most abundant animals on earth?
When James put his slides into the humidity
chamber, he had no notion of what these nematodes
would be facing, and so no expectation of
what he would find.
But when the slides came back out, what he
observed was something he’d only seen once
before, in a drawing done two years ago by
one of his close friends, Katelyn Solbakk.
In it, you can see a nematode
whose body has been clinched
into segments by some kind of bulbous, thing.
What you’re seeing is the fungus’ most
brutal design.
But to get there, it must morph from decomposer
to predator, no longer consuming what has
already been dead, but actively killing.
It begins by weaving a trap out of itself.
It threads the hyphae of its mycelium out
and then back in, forming a living loop that
repeats to form a net.
But a net is only one part of a trap, the
other part is the lure.
The fungi can find nematodes by following
traces of their pheromones like they’re
breadcrumbs.
And more nefariously, they can mimic the smell
of certain food cues to draw the worm in,
like a siren working through scent instead
of song.
The nematode has no reason to suspect anything,
even as it swims closer and closer and eventually
through the fungal rings.
But as it does, the movement of worm and water
triggers the rings to constrict.
The worm is trapped, but the worst is still
yet to come.
The fungus’ hyphae begin to grow off from
the loop, puncturing the worm’s cuticle and paralyzing it.
The threads swell up into a bulb that produces
more hyphae to spread through the rest of the nematode.
And then the fungus feeds and feeds, quickly
digesting the rest of the nematode’s body
from within.
It is a gruesome death.
Here is one nematode, just recently trapped.
And here is the worm again, four days later.
You can see the infection bulb where the fungus
first punctured and expanded.
And the whole body of the worm seems taken
over, no longer a clear tube, but instead
a corpse that has become home to its cause
of death.
The Arthrobotrys fungi are not the only ones
capable of trapping and feeding upon nematodes.
There is a whole range of nematode-trapping
fungi with their own methods, though the species
Arthrobotrys oligospora is perhaps the most
plentiful of these fungi and also the best studied.
Maybe it’s just us, but it’s somewhat
unsettling to realize that this insidiousness
is all the work of a fungus, a thing that
can seem so inert compared to the wiggling,
active worm that it targets.
But fungi do have a kinship with horror stories.
Their frequent role as decomposers naturally
connects them with the dead.
Plus, they come equipped with their own creeping
sense of dread with images of mycelia weaving through bodies.
And authors have drawn inspiration from the
notion of fungal horror.
There are many works--like the famous Gothic
tale We Have Always Lived in the Castle, or
the short story “The Voice in the Night,”
or recent novels like Mexican Gothic and Wanderers—
that draw on everything from poisonous mushrooms
to colonizing fungi to create their terror.
But whatever we seek to scare ourselves with
in fiction, horror has its purpose in nature.
As we’ve pointed out, nematodes are one
of the most abundant animals on earth.
They play an important role in decomposition...but
they’re also the source of many diseases—both
in animal bodies and in plants.
So having them be slightly less abundant is
important to our ecosystem as well.
In fact, scientists have been studying these
fungi to develop better nematode-fighting
strategies for agriculture.
So as is the case with many good horror villains,
there is a version of this story where the
nematode-trapping fungus is the hero.
Unless, of course, you’re the nematode.
And for our last video, our microbes are dying
at the hands of an unusual enemy.
It’s James, with an UV laser, in the laboratory.
Maybe it sounds like a microscopic version of
the game Clue, but there’s a point to it all,
we swear.
Blepharisma have appeared on our channel several
times before.
In fact, this channel got its start thanks
to a video that James, our master of microscopes,
once posted of a Blepharisma dying.
Around three million people watched that video,
including me, your host Hank Green.
So if you enjoy this channel, you can thank
that dead Blepharisma.
But perhaps you should wait for another day
to thank them.
Because in about ten seconds, you’re going
to watch a Blepharisma explode.
Here it is, glowing with autofluorescence
underneath UV light.
You can see its oblong shape and oral groove
outlined in red…but not for long.
The red becomes brighter and brighter, but
it also looks like it’s starting to expand.
And then suddenly, the walls of the blepharisma
burst, the organism popping like a crimson balloon.
The blepharisma bubbles and pours into its
surroundings
and it all happens within a matter of seconds.
Let’s watch it again.
Dead or dying microbes are a common enough
sight in our journey through the microcosmos.
And there are many potential culprits behind
these deaths: predators, accidents, environmental
changes, the inevitable march of life into
death.
But the culprit this time… well, it was
us.
Us and the UV light that is part of our new
fluorescence microscope upgrade.
And our UV light has been very exciting for
us.
In particular, it’s allowed us to look for
methanogens, or Archaea, which sometimes take
up residence inside protists.
Under normal light, it’s hard to tell the
tiny archaea and the tiny bacteria apart.
But under UV light, the archaea will shine
blue.
So UV can reveal new aspects of the microcosmos.
But if you’ve ever fallen asleep on a beach
or just stayed out in the sun a bit too long,
you may have also experienced the darker side
of UV light.
No one wants a sunburn, but fortunately, we
have defenses, like hair, and melanin, and
sunscreen which can block or absorb UV rays
before they cause further damage in our cells.
We also, and this is crucial, have more than
one cell...so if some of them die, which when
you get a sunburn they do, the rest of our
bodies can live on.
Not all organisms have these sorts of protections.
Or if they do, they’re designed for exposure
to the sun, not the intense scrutiny of our UV light.
So when James wants to hunt Archaea, he has
to be careful.
He can quickly shine the UV light to see if
anything blue appears.
But he has to quickly shut it off.
Because as we’ve seen, even a few seconds
of exposure to the UV light will kill off
his pond buddies.
We want to note that as we said earlier, death
is a common reality of the microcosmos…we
just usually prefer to walk in on a microbe
dying rather than being the cause of death.
But for this episode, we decided to make an
exception and use our UV light for an extended
period of time, with the knowledge that it
would kill the microbe we were watching.
Because these explosions illustrate the cost
of doing business with light.
The word for this business is phototoxicity.
Death by light.
And while it can happen under other monochromatic
lights, the particular wavelength and intensity
of our UV light makes it much more harmful
to our organisms than our other red, blue,
or green light sources.
This death starts with excitation.
When the light hits the organism, it can potentially
excite chemical structures inside the cell,
sending electrons up and down, and producing
fluorescent colors in the process.
But the colors aren’t the only
thing that gets created.
If there’s oxygen around, it will react
with the excited fluorescent molecule, creating
what are known as reactive oxygen species.
In biology, reactive oxygen species are byproducts
of different cellular processes that metabolize
oxygen, which can make them part of normal
life.
There are even reactive oxygen species that
are involved in signaling pathways.
But the “reactive” in their name is key
to what makes an excess amount of them dangerous.
If you are an organism, and you are, there
are a lot of reactions you want to have happen
in your cells.
You want your DNA to link together correctly,
you want your enzymes to find the right substrates.
But reactive oxygen species are happy to react
with all of those molecules too, damaging
them and getting in the way of the chemistry
that we need to survive.
What phototoxicity will look like depends
on the organism and the light being directed at it.
For the organisms we’ve been showing here,
like this homalozoon, the overall effect of
this intense UV light seems to be unanimous:
the cell swells up and bursts open, like a
galaxy erupting on our slide.
But while the overall effect is the same,
the internal machinations are likely different,
triggered by a complex interplay of different
chemicals that nonetheless react to our light
source in a similar, catastrophic fashion.
While we’re not sure of the culprits behind
the homalozoon’s death, we can identify
one of the chemicals that likely sets off
the blepharisma’s death.
It’s the reddish pigment molecule called
blepharismin that gives the ciliate its color
under more normal circumstances.
Outside of the UV light, you can see the membrane-bound
pigments neatly distributed along the rows
that stretch from one end of the blepharisma
to the other.
But under our UV light and with oxygen in
the environment, the blepharismin reacts to
form reactive oxygen species, and death follows
quickly from there.
But while toxic in our experiment, we should
note that the blepharismin serves a key purpose
for the blepharisma: defense.
These pigment molecules are toxic to some
of Blepharisma’s predators in both the light
and the dark.
That makes the pigment somewhat like UV light:
necessary for survival, yet also a delicate negotiation.
But in the same way that we manage our relationship
with the sun, scientists have learned ways
to manage these phototoxic reactions.
They’ve had to in order to understand how
we can use fluorescence microscopy to study
cells and organisms.
They’ve learned how to modulate wavelength
and intensity and duration, along with many
other factors, to wield light in a way that
better serves their purposes.
In the case of the blepharisma, for example,
scientists found that using a moderate light
for around 1 hour wasn’t much of a problem
for them.
But with more time under the light, the cells
would eventually die.
It’s easy to think of the microcosmos as
a separate world from us, even when we know
that the microscope is a bridge between large
and small.
But these deaths at the hand of our supposed
bridge are a cautionary sign that we are encountering
microbes in a world that is both natural and
manufactured at the same time.
The way that we light that world impacts the
way we see the organisms, and it also shapes
their lives—reminding us that they are stronger
often than we can fathom, but fragile nonetheless.
And that brings us to the end of our tour of death
in the microcosmos today,
an end to a story of ends, you might say.
But maybe what we’ve seen today is that
there really is no end, is there?
Just pauses on individual stories that nonetheless
endure in the remains of the world left behind.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to all of our patrons who make
videos like the ones we’ve watched today possible.
This channel could not exist without your
support and we are so thankful for it.
If you’d like to join the list of patrons
you’re currently seeing on your screen,
you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
And if you’d like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram, and if you’d
like to see more from us, there’s probably
a subscribe button somewhere nearby.